foreign
is organized knowledge wisdom is
organized life
he who is cruel to animals becomes hard
also in his dealings with men we can
judge the heart of a man by his
treatment of animals
with a lie a man annihilates his dignity
as a man
it is not God's will merely that we
should be happy but that we should make
ourselves happy
a person is only a person when he has
the power to make sense of his
surroundings
[Music]
so act that your principle of action May
safely be made a law for the whole world
morality is not the doctrine of how we
make ourselves happy but how we make
ourselves worthy of happiness
out of Timber so crooked as that from
which man is made
nothing entirely straight can be carved
in law a man is guilty when he violates
the rights of others in ethics he is
guilty if he only thinks of doing so
[Music]
nothing is divine but what is agreeable
to reason
[Music]
all human knowledge begins with
intuition proceeds from thence to
concept and ends with ideas
an organized product of nature is that
in which all the parts are mutually ends
and means
God put a secret art into the forces of
nature so as to enable it to Fashion
itself out of chaos into a perfect world
system
[Music]
you only know me as you see me not as I
actually am
[Music]
notion without intuition is empty
intuition without notion is blind
all our knowledge begins with the senses
proceeds then to the understanding and
ends with reason
there is nothing higher than reason
Al then is perfection to be sought
wherein lies our hope in education and
in nothing else
[Music]
genius is the ability to independently
arrive at and understand Concepts that
would normally have to be taught by
another person
the death of Dogma is the birth of
morality
have patience Slanders are not
long-lived truth is the Child of Time
air long she shall appear to vindicate
thee
look closely the beautiful may be small
[Music]
for peace to Reign on Earth humans must
evolve into new beings who have learned
to see the whole
the busier we are the more acutely we
feel that we live the more conscious we
are of life
we are not rich by what we possess but
by what we can do without
the whole people perish than Injustice
be done
what might be said of things in
themselves separated from all
relationship to our senses remains for
us absolutely unknown
dignity is the value that creates
irreplaceability
simply to acquiesce in skepticism can
never suffice to overcome the
restlessness of reason
the reading of all good books is like a
conversation with the finest minds of
past centuries
settle for sure and universally what
conduct will promote the happiness of a
rational being
all perception is colored by emotion
the greatest human Quest is to know what
one must do in order to become a human
being
maturity is Having the courage to use
one's own intelligence
great minds think for themselves
one is not rich by what one owns but
more by what one is able to do with
dignity
honesty is better than any policy
one who makes himself a worm cannot
complain afterwards if people step on
him
two things are me most The Starry Sky
above me and the moral law Within Me
life is the faculty of spontaneous
activity the awareness that we have
power
freedom is the opposite of necessity
do the right thing because it is right
[Music]
always recognize that human individuals
are ends and do not use them as means to
your end
[Music]
Freedom can never be comprehended nor
even can insight into it be gained
the only thing permanent is change
[Music]
freedom is that faculty that enlarges
the usefulness of all other faculties
[Music]
it is never too late to become
reasonable and wise
[Music]
art is purposiveness without purpose
God freedom and immortality are
untenable in the light of pure reason
the only thing that is good without
qualification is good will
foreign to be is to do
experience without theory is blind but
Theory without experience is mere
intellectual play
religion is the recognition of all our
duties as Divine commands
ingratitude is the essence of vileness
I had therefore to remove knowledge in
order to make room for belief
metaphysics is a dark ocean without
Shores or Lighthouse strewn with many a
philosophic wreck
[Music]
even philosophers will praise War as an
obling mankind forgetting the Greek who
said war is bad in that it begets more
evil than it kills
only the descent into hell of
self-knowledge can pave the way to
Godliness
Enlightenment is man's emergence from
his self-incurred immaturity
and must be disciplined for he is by
nature raw and Wild
dare to know have the courage to use
your own intelligence
Thrift is care and scruple in the
spending of one's means
it is not a virtue and it requires
neither skill nor Talent
[Music]
rules for happiness something to do
someone to love something to hope for
[Music]
all false art all vain wisdom lasts its
time but finally destroys itself
and its highest culture is also the
epoch of its decay
[Music]
three things tell a man his eyes his
friends and his favorite quotes
[Music]
patience is the strength of the weak
impatience is the weakness of the strong
[Music]